the media accused of a double standard
when it comes to covering republican
women imagine that so the new york times
being called out for referring to texas
republican congresswoman maya flores as
a far-right latina flora is hitting back
saying i have received only hate from
the liberal media and constantly been
told by the left to go back to mexico
the new york times knows nothing about
me or our culture others quick to point
out the stark contrast between coverage
of flores political success and aoc's
for example aoc gracing the covers of
multiple publications getting invited to
the met gala always being praised and i
don't think that maya flores jesse
expected to be on the cover of any
magazines but the new york times
headlines about aoc versus that of maya
flores it's i am
rarely surprised but it was still
shocking yeah it's pretty stark the
contrast she shouldn't have spoken to
the new york times that's my advice to
everybody
i see it like this way you have
republican you have conservative
you have right wing
you have hard right
and then you have far right
you don't want to be far right so i have
some advice for people on how not to get
labeled far right because what they do
the libs
especially the new york times far right
is considered q anon
conspiracy theory
election
stuff all right now you never do
anything with q ignore q and this is
when they ask you is joe biden the
legitimate president of the united
states this is what you say if you're a
republican and you're getting smeared as
a far-right lunatic yes you say yes he
is
the president he was certified he was
inaugurated and he wound up with the
most votes but
that election was not fair and here are
three reasons why now these are
indisputable facts that you could just
throw that in their face number one
big tech and big media conspired to
suppress the republican october surprise
the laptop mark zuckerberg spent half a
billion dollars
layering over
a private army of election activists on
top of the local election officials and
you have all these democrat lawyers who
sued everybody extended deadlines
weakened signature requirements and then
allowed all these unsolicited ballots to
be blasted off no verifiable chain of
custody you hammer those three facts
home
and you say i want election integrity
because i want people to trust the
elections in this country and that's how
you don't get labeled far right it's
that simple take it from me all right
judge let's get back to maya flores that
was excellent that's my advice to flores
and all you people out there when it
comes to the the contrast
look
what is happening now are traditional
american values are being trashed as
extreme as outrageous i mean look this
is a country found on judeo-christian
ethics okay this is in my courtroom in
most courtrooms in this country they say
in god we trust it's even on our money
okay and the truth is that we they are
pushing us away from religion and she is
a traditionalist in terms of her beliefs
and so it's not even about calling
someone racist anymore because that word
doesn't even have the sting that it used
to have you know the worst thing the
life could call you is a racist but it
really was never about that it's about
ideology
and so when they want to trash you
they'll say you are racist or you're an
extremist but that has no meaning the
only thing they're saying is that you
are someone who is so far out of the
norm when the truth is they're the ones
that are so far out of the norm they're
the ones who are trying to change the
reality and the legitimacy of who we are
as a god-fearing nation founded on these
principles in terms of you know the the
right and wrong and law and order and
you know now that these latinas or
latinos or whatever are being elected
they're being seen as a threat because
joe biden only is 26 percent of them who
favor him and they know that once they
lose some of the bigger ones the rest of
the latinos are going to be very
comfortable leaving joe biden so they've
got to demonize them as extremists
that's a good question then for harold
about the the left and the democrats are
already losing support from latinos at a
pretty steady level but when they start
being elected especially in those border
towns republicans don't have to win the
entire latino vote they just need to win
some more of it and i can't imagine that
the democrats think overall that this is
a good idea but they seem to always do
this to somebody like maya flores there
are 100 republican candidates across the
country that are hispanic it's the
biggest number republicans have ever had
i think when politicians complain about
press coverage
it's like a batter complaining about a
little ump call you got to keep going
with the game you can't complain about
referee calling here uh the new york
times remember biden criticized the new
york times he and he and claine said
that they weren't being treated fairly
by the times and look the time just
treated a lot of people unfairly
democrat republican alike this is a
little bit different no no but i differ
i think democrats and republicans the
best you can do when you're a politician
don't make it about yourself
as much as this young congresswoman who
i've applauded her victory she beat a
democrat and democrats are saying well
it was a low turnout to that race
doesn't matter democrats don't kid
yourself that race does matter but when
you when you focus on the voters and you
focus on the things that you want to
deliver you want to make schools safer
you want to make the border safer give
us animate us not with your emotion
about the new york times calling you or
suggesting getting not giving you the
coverage that aoc uh has people in your
district want you to represent them
lay out what you plan to do a different
pile here just say yes don't do all that
stuff you're talking
liberals and democrats telling her this
american congresswoman who was born in
mexico they're telling her to go back to
mexico but nobody else yeah that's
pretty funny i think they're mad because
they couldn't thwart this historical
first if she had been a democrat they
would be parading her around like a
clydesdale horse uh you know
and
if you kind of look at it's kind of an
interesting pattern and
they might say it's proof that they're
not racist right when when the row a
decision came down there were six votes
but the left focused their wrath on
clarence thomas that's right uh the
conservative got the most wrath running
for governor was larry elder who which
they call the face of the black face of
white supremacy there's other examples
of where they where the left focuses on
the minority conservative uh and and
their argument being that okay that's it
has nothing to do with skin color it has
to do with values it's like i don't like
these blacks but i like these blacks i
don't like these hispanics but i like
these actually it is racist because what
you're what you're actually saying is
you don't like blacks or or hispanics
who don't agree who don't
aren't subservient to your ideology so
that's just as racist it's like if you
don't do what i say then you're just
like those people ooh gross go back to
mexico
but we at the five would like to
congratulate maya flores yes her victory
and becoming the first congresswoman
born in mexico hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else